both on the road and throughout the
skies folks are flocking to vegas to
celebrate labor day of course but
transmission of the coronavirus
continues to be a major issue orca mana
shares how visitors plan to stay safe
i'm excited i'm meeting my son here this
weekend whether it's visiting a family
member we're excited too we're excited
to travel and excited to be out or
partying on the strip
it's clear las vegas is the place to be
on labor day weekend it's one of the top
travel destinations in the country right
now with hotel bookings in august 2021
outpacing those of august 2019 there's
huge demand even as coven 19 concerns
continue i'm going to keep my distance
this woman plans to be extra cautious
because of the delta variant she knows
large crowds can be risky but says there
are only so many steps she can take
wearing your mask protecting yourself
cleaning your hands is all you can do
because you never know the cdc is
recommending those unvaccinated against
covet 19 should not travel this holiday
weekend and even if you are vaccinated
you should weigh the risks but this
couple says they felt fine on their
flight everybody was wearing their masks
i mean there's pretty much no there was
no like people trying to not wear them
and start a big scene like there has
been the big message from health
officials do your part to stop the
spread to stay safe everyone orcomanna 8
news now